hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
agile automation strategies in a genomic
core facility i am michelle action of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labyrinth and
brought to you by Beckman Coulter to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.hp.com/recycle
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send only answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation on the
support tab found at the top-right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask question
box located on the far left of your
screen this presentation is educational
and best offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
of the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credit I now
present today's speaker
Juergen Simran the senior engineer at
the gen core facility in Heidelberg
Germany for a complete biography on our
speakers please visit the BIOS UB tab at
the top of your screen again you may now
begin your presentation
today I'd like to talk about the
automation strategies at gene pool this
particularly focusing on signal sequence
e-library preparation applications but
before I'd like to give you a fraud over
floor about EMBL then actually the
structure of gene core and our
automation considerations before I come
then finally to our single cell
sequencing methods embolism
intergovernmental organization founded
in 1974 by Sir John Kendrew and James
Watson it's currently funded by 26
member states and some additional says
they are mainly located coming mainly
located in Europe but also Australia
Israel and Argentina are no members
embolus located at six different sides
the main laboratory is located in
Heidelberg actual biology has private
beam lines at the Daisy and Petra in
Hamburg as ability is I think run over
by bioinformatics outstation the EBI is
located in Hingston additional out
stations in Barcelona and Rome are
concentrating on disease modeling and
neural biology amble already
concentrated quite early competence and
technologies and certain power
facilities have started this DAA
advanced light microscopy facility the
electron microscopy facility and
genomics and well other portfolio
summing up currently 210 facilities
Co facilities as well as the EMBL itself
is collaborating with a broad range of
industries like instrument companies
like Beckman Olympus and like up as well
as biochemical instrument while chemical
companies like any B or alumina as well
as others and a broad range of
pharmaceutical companies like Purina
gene pool itself is currently a user
base of 800 users coming worldwide our
user base is limited to members from the
laboratory itself as well as certain
scientific programs like Young
Investigator Program which is actually
world wild or medical research programs
in the next slide I'd like to give you
an overview about the tremendous changes
and grossest encounter since the last
years
grows over the last eight years was
coming close to accent exceptional
growth and at the same time our
resources remain more more or less
constant so the headcount
ranges between five and seven and our
automation instruments really drop by
50% the reason for the last is that
actually we change from very inefficient
instruments quite efficient instruments
from from Beckman right now I also like
to give you a the overview about the
quite heterogeneous population of
samples we are dealing with so mainly of
course it's human and mouse but actually
that West spends really between Apple
viruses
deep sea urchin extremophiles and from
other sample types in the next two
slides you will see really quite a
dynamics of the needs of the users we
are serving just between two years here
you see that an ASIC is currently
contributing this 22% in over sequencing
with five percent and for example chip
seeked with fifteen percent one year
later the picture looks totally
different we are dealing with 52% of our
ASIC
but the no war sequencing is really
triplicated and chip seek remains
constant you see also the Quantic
sequencing is slowly evolving so the
next year it will look totally different
again I can promise you this is mainly
driven by the availability of new
instrumentation from the beginning of
2008 with a very limited beginning for
massive parallel sequencing and evolved
into the Illumina sequencer systems like
2000-2500 no 4000 then the next week
system came and this good ion we have
here currently and this Dominion also
the novo sequencing field opens
it also in how well it's accepted by the
users we have so initially 2014 only
high six requests were down and this
will mainly replace completely by next
stick using
now I like to continue with some
automation considerations actually what
are the criteria
gingka is following for deciding the
instruments running their projects and
actually what are they're mainly taking
calc before we're deciding for an
instrument and how we are running the
automation procedures afterwards so this
is a slide from that venue which I
really like shows the different states
you are undergoing under we all have
really a full-functioning system and
actually the cost commitment you have so
actually you have in the beginning a
very high failure rate
hopefully with low investment and at the
end you should end with a very high
throughput of this low failure rate so
initially you are starting with the
design phase we actually make it design
a process map make some base minimal
baseline how it should work at the end
in the next step of development you're
developing your protocols may be a
prototype they all act like to go in
there so everything should get clear you
should see the first result at this step
already the next step which is the most
critical and the most demanding on get
the whole thing stable that you really
can rely on it when you're going to
upscale into the final production phase
so if your goal starting this pre
designed protocols you get these phases
are quite short and actually there
shouldn't be so much risk and down in
this gateway Arabians you have to do but
if you are starting this friendly new
one it can get demand
so now coming just to the project
considerations if you are going for
automation and instrument selection so
it's always good to start as a short
detailed documentation of requirements
what you really need and where you like
to like to go and you should stick to
that any changes viewing it may cause
drastic delay and in the worst case
scenario in more cost one of the basic
criteria should be the throughput
actually what is your current throughput
you like to cover but also you should
have a very reliable gross estimate for
the future okay there is a lot of
variation in there you don't know how
the user needs are developing but you
should make it roughly between ten
fifteen or even more percent
but to really come to a precise design
of the system you should make a critical
pathway analysis also finding the rate
limiting step is really the pipe adding
the right rate limiting step or is it a
PCR machine incubation times or
whatsoever and this will really guide
the design of the system and further
decisions the question is do you like
for a dedicated system which can do
things and very high throughput but
limited number of applications it can
handle or if you like to do with a
modular automation where you have all
the flexibility you need even if the
chemistry is out of session in the next
six months and you have to do something
different the instrument specs forget
from the companies when you're deciding
for a system should be chosen only as
guidelines mainly they are one is water
and some furthermore artificial
considerations so take them as a
guideline but also be prepared that
there may not fit your specific need but
on a positive side the companies also
quite conservative to guarantee the
functionality so sometimes they are also
surprised how much you can get out of
this
would also go into the discussion where
do you like to save most your costs do
you think you can save it and work can
you save it in consumables and chemistry
of which other parameters are most
important this is also this is precise
in a way you should be aware that this
plug-and-play protocols you always get
offered from companies most of the time
allusions also made under certain
artificial assumptions which are behind
there
so if you are planning for project time
always assume a longer period for that
priorities so initially you should go
for the car functions that you can
deliver results primarily and in the
second step you're going for supportive
functionality you need in your process
interfacing if you have a limb structure
or other systems will like automatically
document what's happening on the machine
or in a workflow may be a little bit
demanding also because sometimes the
api's between the systems are not
compatible in the way so I mentioned
here an artificial heart which is named
art this is a core functionality in the
Beckman systems we decided for which
take already most of the work out of
your hands before it's going to limb
system or any other things one main
coach area is of course easy to use
software but actually I put the easiness
especially in quotation marks because
easiness is really a wide field using
this fast is quite simple so even if you
are a newbie and the instrument has been
set up and the application engineer has
given you an introduction to you the
next day you should be able at least to
set up a small easy program like moving
plates around pipetting liquid from one
place to another in an hour everything
which takes longer is not that easy to
use software
there should be training available which
makes it very fast independently one or
two training trainings software training
should be enough to put you in the
position that you are independent but
most of the jobs you are doing if
proper development tools which allow an
automatic versioning which a purpose of
the documentation which helps you in
asking most of your questions
election of lenda is a another parameter
it should be reliable the company should
be existence for some time already and
it should be responsive if you ask your
questions they should offer sustainable
maintenance and support because you may
need it and if they don't have the
personnel your cover you need them it's
a problem especially for call facilities
ask for references from others they are
always quite helpful and in all the
projects we are starting think of some
unexpected to happen which means for
example that the company who's
delivering the microtiter plates can't
deliver for six weeks or something and
then the whole project may get in to
delay because as the robotic companies
have also the schedules to plan this
method considerations are also and
except if you like to go more granular
in the process so in according to our
experience no manual protocol is mapping
one to one to an automated version so
don't stick to a written protocol
totally there are a lot of parameters
you have to change and this is the
experience are actually the companies
offering to you who's automating the
process and also the experience of the
biochemical supplier you have but
sometimes they are contradiction I have
to warn you in that but there are the
automation experience is superseding the
paper protocol definitely so we have
several cases we just have to adjust
like mixing like other parameters and
then it works much better so at the end
the stability and the reproducibility of
your results should be the first aim
you should be always aware of protocol
mists like the fresh ethanol if you
check your old physical chemistry books
you would see that ethanol has gone into
saturation within two five to six
minutes so they're fresh let up doesn't
help too much the stability of the
chemicals for example also there the
biochemical companies are very
restrictive and conservative though
there's always more additional times in
storage at room temperature for example
before mixing procedures need to be
optimized in some cases you will
encounter lower yields with basic
settings you also found in manual
protocols so it's but you have the
possibility to adjust just added an
additional PCR cycle would cover but
there are also protocols where robots
definitely get better the better the
better results then the manual protocols
you get from the counter
we are definitely have to be aware are
dead volumes most kid suppliers have the
very limited amounts of stock chemicals
in there and there you sometimes have to
use additional chemistry next parameter
is on that PCR off take PCR gene code
asides definitely for full worker Bay
automation and so the on deck PCR was
necessary already from the beginning but
we check it with a lot of biochemical
tests I will come to this results later
so you can have a short look and write
on your own washing tips
maybe really strange for you but it's
really depending on the design of the
washing station so the washing station
we have found on the bio mix have
individual wash bolts with active flow
and pipetting we made the calculation
that actually we have delusion factors
which are going tend to the power of 30
something and actually actually we made
also biochemical testing to be on the
safe side and so we kept the step in
there
one thing is a regular calibration one
of the instruments for QC and agree on a
realistic SAT so the final result should
be compare comparable to manual results
and you should always do the burn in
tests with control samples and with a
functional validated a chemical tip to
be sure that no other influences are
there if you have a wide variety of
samples like we have in a core facility
you can do this other tests later but
initially you need to know is the kid
running is the robot funny you should
expect realistic standard deviation and
CVS and foods in pipetting that's for
now based on this initial criteria we
came to define and set up and said ok we
like to have 52 2500 samples per week
real active real worker babe
we like to change protocols in a very
fast manner as you see this was
necessary from the initial graph and we
like to go with modular automation it's
much easier to have by another robot
doing the same functionality or adding
just later hotels or something like that
to scale up no dedicated machine and we
like to have at the final aim increased
process control we use human interaction
and improve the consistency between the
far but our current automation
infrastructure you are seeing here we
have to buy Omega 6 piece so boost all
heads this dose we are operating since
2011 and we have a biomech e 7 pictures
in our house in 2017 so here already on
the Volt in quotation marks FX PUC an
integrated PCR cycler it can do the PCR
doing the Allah
the controlled incubations at higher
temperatures and it can be used for
hybridization reactions in the
background you see pal cheese for
cooling for stop chemicals and you have
some space for plates and tips the i7 is
a much higher capacity more than twice
the detailed picture you see later so
now I come to the implementation
criteria in one example so here you see
on several cases the comparison between
two sequencing kit the most important
ones are on the upper right and the
lower list on the horizontal Lane you
see the content of CG and on the
vertical line you see some arbitrary
values for read counts the upper right
picture shows a very neat distribution
of read counts really independent of the
GC content where the other kit is really
failing in higher ad content and also
declining in GC content
sure about the chemistry you like to
automate that first point in there
the next question is does the machine
block here we have the case that they
actually checked a channel machine from
from another company so we checked it in
five repetitions on five columns so on
the horizontal nine are the channel
numbers on the vertical lane you see the
absorbance we stopped our team and
actually you see over a lot of
physicians a large variation between
individual channels and actually also
position why disappointed positional
effects actually the aim was to see the
distribution of channel eight everywhere
but company was not able to achieve this
sort of machine gun back these are the
results we get from the biomech with a
96-well head on the upper left you see
the calibration for different volumes of
on the lower picture you see just the
accuracy or inaccuracy over complete 996
well and on the right side you see the
the CV very end over the plate so if
you're going to the calculation over all
of the plates you see an inaccuracy from
three point one 1% and 4% CV and that's
for 5 microliters a three
now they come into the functional test
so the initial test is just a standard
we like to see as a delivery amount okay
so here we have based on any be DNA kids
we see 50 nano grams per microliter
that's okay and the next step we are
going to affordability within a plate
quite neat
the next step is we are looking for
reproducibility over the run and again
past the next thing is after variable
size selection works also here the next
thing is this cross contamination trick
so I mentioned before so we went with
checkerboard complete microtiter plate
is filters all reactants with the
exception of the template we add the
template only to each second girl
horizontally and vertically so each
second well should be empty which you
see here if we did the same thing with
endpoint PCR we also make bioinformatics
check adding adjacent to each other
different organisms and it was also not
detectable there so all the things were
passed and actually these are the basic
creatine before we went to the
automation protocols you see here so
it's alumina it's true saccade on a then
from anyway we have several ones like on
a directional with and without reliable
depletion we have any be single cell on
any we we call this chip sakes any
beware we have a cancer hot pot hot spot
panel with this brilliant result and one
sake there's another plenty of exome
capture with shrew select another single
cell protocol this is friend seek from
Ashley Sanders and then several
logistical functions like reformatting
for fragment analyzer to Hindi indexing
this volume checking love this takara
smart cig is another single cell
protocol I will show later
and strand tech is another single cell t
& v a single cell been sick HT a single
cell and we have another set of
protocols we are currently working on so
now I like to switch to the sample
applications where we go to some single
cell methods now here we have some
additional considerations we have to
mate to prevent really loss of single
cells during the process so initially we
are not making any dos material transfer
to any sister plate we are taking fresh
tips in our transfer just with the
exception of Keibler's also to prevent
accidentally transfer most of the
protocols you'll see later have segments
ation steps which are time critical so
all the plates you have to process in
time sync to prevent any unrep
reducibility there we have to use low
retention plastics we have to add a
pulse to catch more droplets which may
remain at the well of the tubes after
mixing so we have to optimize our mixing
procedures for the small volumes and we
have to reduce drastically the deadlines
so part protocol started this flow
sorted based on a beardy melody system
which to double staining the second
stain is to distinguish between debt and
the life cells
then this says our deficit by disorder
and certain type of plates we have a
positive control in there with a spot
Penza assorted pencils into a plate
volume which you see the cookies are
becoming quite quite faster and we have
negative control
so let's start with Picaro so the first
step is propriety
so it's Takada's Mattituck I think which
is very known by now and actually it's
starting with sorting the cell nicing
then it's a one step seed in our
synthesis and amplification
crucification to normal ray and then we
have next NextEra xt from alumina or the
library preparation
so this is the Burke flow as it is seen
on the biomech i7 so it's very
transparent so everything is clickable
and resolvable to individual steps this
is for the pre dispensing the license
plate which is contrary to our queen
then we have to see DNA synthesis below
and the next step in the tree is the
library preparation segmentation and
presence
all is accompanied by IDing the plates
which allows them both recording all the
initial and all the final and order
transitional step
if you look at the user interface I see
that we can
whole protocol completely or in all of
this three individual steps we have
selected for on Dec cycler point of your
processing here 96 sampled and you can
select the different options so you see
the plates our plates are resource
plates are littered and then we have a
PCR lid for the integrated psi Club
and these are the results of roughly we
are with 100 microgram per microliters
of iron range of the proposed values
from a car or to continue for the next
step so here we have the next step
that's the library preparation attack
documentation here the tips looking a
little bit different they are already
lead it and down and those are prepared
for the next step for higher throughput
so we can process more samples and next
version of the protocol
also here we see an individual library
from from the first serious the amount
of tape and in the beginning you see a
small spike and actually already in the
next version of the protocol we have
been moved it successfully because we
made some modification in the
predication put a protocol and the
second one would tamper so from that
point of view the photo colors has
already passed our criteria the next
protocol is map next single cell it's
based all also on a license of the cells
the next step is to very reverse
transcription is a template switching
then DNA amplification clean up and then
it's following the normal anyb library
preparation procedure
here we are limited to 90s examples
everything most of the deck is used and
also here you can parameters like which
are necessary to change and allow
flexibility or reprogram
so here we have quoted a comparison
between a single cell library and poulos
individual examples and it's all
comparable to many or driven samples the
next protocol is a little bit
outstanding as the initial ones deal
with RNA this is a protocol dealing with
DNA and also it has a different purposes
not it's using strength seek but the
main purpose is not equal to itself it's
for tracking common loaders within a
cell
by incorporating from the u.s. field
during cell division you can my you can
mark even the individual spans and track
those doing the whole process at the end
you can strength get strength specific
high resolution information about
genomic rearrangements
and this is currently out there so in
the first step you isolated the cells
then you're doing the fara sorting the
procedures as before then it's
continuing with some MNH treatment
followed by end with a tailing so then
you have the UV hooks treatment to
provide to provoke strength making and
then you're going the PCR amplification
and then the conventional DNA analysis
and you're looking at a small picture 70
steps 77 to 81 you Syria the analysis
just the details are not important but
you see over there that you have green
dashes at yellow dashes which has the
best reciprocal on the different
chromosomes and patrols you already
what's going on now so the initial setup
was based on the effects and now we are
on the i7 because we'd like to have a
full walk away and shorting the running
time by 50% we are now able to shorten
the running time on the FX already by
30% by some protocol changes we'd like
to do scaling bound where we are already
successful for the factor of two and we
like to do math on experience it was not
possible under fix because of tech
limitation because here we just have in
total
[Music]
sixteen open positions one Mississippi
robot itself then we have the orbital
30s and then we have both positions love
the deck for betting these are the steps
which are also as modular as in the
other protocol SS AF seen build meas
treatment and repair a tailing Legation
and was a lot of purification in between
pieces tendon layer out on on the i7 and
die OCD capacity we run through and even
using the additional leather feeders we
are seeing on the left side here it's
allowing to stick a lot of plates and
tip boxes and below the deck after
instrument itself and we have a barcode
reader
on the results you see a very nice
comparison between the biomega and human
pipettor and you see that the coverage
is substantially higher going up to the
windows 0:05 and the map reads are in
the power of 10 higher and the human
operator this is if you look at more
statistics I think currently we are more
than close to 40,000 libraries the
success rate is quite high and the
detection levels of rearrangements on
all of the robots we have seen so far is
much better than on the
so my conclusion is that the flexible
automation we have gone for with the
Beckman instruments can cope is the fast
throughput increases based vs8 the
varying demands and I would like to add
that even the conventional automation
systems which are available now easy to
handle single-cell applications in our
lab liquid handlers can be better than
human operators and dot quality and
automation methods we have achieved our
stable pool of a walk away automation
including on the PC our possible
election are also needed
so here are the list of our
collaborators this is milder Ashley and
within EMBL adding me as the head of
genomics core facility Paris and Lauer
has started on the biomech we get great
support from Martine tough and Alicia
from Beckman and from the other
companies from the protocols it was not
able to snow here this is our team
pictures and thank you very much for
your attention
thank you you're going for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask so
you see so now just click on the ask
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for ok let's
get started
our first question is can you give us
some more details about cost savings
actually three three factors
contributing and costs one is the Newman
work the second the plastic disposable
is and the third one are the consumables
in human work you have
set-up time on the robot which is
roughly for our complicated protocol
half an hour's you have to take em into
account which mean setting up the plates
are covering the deck and preparing the
master mixes they I would say that's the
only thing which is then used for the
protocol so if you have to substantial
throughput and the whole thing then it
saves to complete a position if the
swoop would is lower then you said
people really free from repetitive work
and also more demanding work still for
the jobs a robot come to offer further
development so I think this is the most
substantial factor
one for the disposables this is really a
point where you have taken into account
do you like to wash tips or not if you
are have certain steps they are like to
be used tips and to wash tips then you
can save up to 20% down also depending
on the support and conditions how you
can buy tips but the chemicals are there
they have to take into account two
additional parameters a is that imprint
upon the dead volumes you have to use on
a machine are slightly higher
and a manual operator is able to really
catch a small droplet out of a tube and
actually robots can can't do this so
this is definitely would mean more costs
in there but on the other side if you
are able to downscale protocols which is
partially possible with some of them
some of them are factor for sometimes -
sometimes not so in some of the cases
you can gain also post sailings down in
the range of 30% 40% and on the other
side you have to take into account it
may be even slightly more expensive but
which is actually covered completely by
the savings and lock
thank you okay your next question how
long does it take to implement a method
realistically
frankly speaking a month you may think
that that steps a long number a long
time however you have to see the
following it can be happy when it's
shorter we also have implementations
with just last week
but you have to take into account the
following things so for
to protocol let's let's assume you have
a premade protocol setting up our it on
the machine
adapted to working they take our as a
matter of days a middle of the day sorry
then running a dry run to see that there
are no high offices in India it's also
matter of hours the same thing with a
wet run so that's that's clear but
they're not coming coming the next phase
and this is based out of the interaction
with the lab because it starts with
control samples those running a library
will take six hours ten hours that's
really depending on the protocol itself
then it's going to cool a so then and
then it's going for sequencing for the
initial test runs if you make the run
first go on those four samples that can
be handled in in a day but if you're
going them to eight and twelve samples
to make really a small scaling out tests
this which I would be the next one then
you have to go on the sequencer to take
sixteen hours 12 hours it's really
depending which sequencer and which
information you like to have so it can
take several days until you have to
result and note that it's really working
so the delays are coming from from the
back and on average what I have seen is
it's very important that interaction
with the lab personnel is working that
there's really an assistant a lab mate
on the other side who is then helping to
the vacation specialist to set it up and
that's definitely a point we have
everything in in-house which make makes
it easy so this is definitely shorting
and you should be aware
sometime a plastic company or even a
large company which is a major player in
sequencing it's not able to deliver in
time and also we robotic companies have
their schedules and sometimes it may
cause delays so be happy about a week I
think technically realistic are two
weeks but this order things happening
around I think a monster
you okay this next question is a
two-part question you mentioned lower
library yield any explanation and how
about data quality
um that's
good question I have have to admit
neither V or the biotech companies we
have contacted have an explanation why
why this is there and because everything
was right and done in a proper way
there was no criticism coming from from
death side but we saw it on the other
hand we have also done protocols with
higher yields and in better data quality
you have seen it like in the strength of
protocol here it's also for example in
the cancer panel protocol where they
actually get a factor of 10 better in
some coverage values and we are better
and also some detection values and
currently this unclear so we just have
to live in it and we can compensate it
and I think that's that's the most
important thing and in all the cases
where compensated for example this one
single additional PCR cycle in the worst
case scenario we don't see worsening of
the data quality there it's identical
that's the point as we see it in the
tradition currently we are producing 80
thousand samples a year and currently we
haven't seen any decline
great thank you okay we have another
two-part question how stable are the
implemented protocols and how stable are
the robots running
let's start with the second part
the robots are stable they get only in
stable if you make a crash so this is
mainly driven by user error if they are
placing wrong hardware on wrong
positions and this can get into a crash
most of the cases can be healed more or
less on his own but just by the process
like framing a user can do and on his
own and in some rare cases our repair
needed something but this is mainly
driven by a user and the very end user
which taking care nothing happening
nevertheless I would consider some
preventive maintenance and some regular
checking but I've suggested in my talk
was also this regular checking of the
pipetting accuracy but actually when we
started we checked it every month and
now we are in the range of at least six
months and we haven't seen any major
change in those values and so we are
quite confident that we have a stable
automated infrastructure here what a
cost ability the only factors which are
10 influence a protocol stability we
have seen and how our lab is that
actually instability of the clips we get
delivered and there's also some one
large provider of sequencing kit which
is bound to some instrument and there we
had sometimes variabilities in the kids
for some components are misbehaving and
describe you to a complete failure and
there you have really to be careful
before charging a robot will be checking
the chemistry and in another from
another company you get different
efficiency in primers and so there we
have differently cases where they saw
that it's driven by
the kids themselves if
always good to have a control during the
runs if you like like to feel safe in
that point but if the protocols have
been developed develop properly and if
you have one after your fi t some real
real samples coming from your service
environment where you would say okay
this is an average sample this is a
difficult sample it's a good sample then
you had already a very good impression
our stable you put
but actually in our hands is fun
protocol has been set up once the
company of the chemistry is stable then
we are running the protocol for ages
currently we started with two sig RNA
just really early in the beginning of
automation period here and the protocol
is running unmodified now I think for
five years so I think roughly five yes
thank you all right it looks like we
have time for one more question how many
samples can be run with the decorum
method yes sir you have seen the
different numbers on it on the two
screens so on so actually currently it's
designed for 192 samples in a run
and we are currently making some
estimates how we can handle it in a
different way to even go further up in a
single one but currently with the
current design 192 is achievable
thank you again your again for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor Beckman Coulter for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today they're
interesting questions questions we did
not have time today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration lab route school or you via
email when this webinar is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may miss
today's event until next time bye